S
GOING TO BE RUN OFF IN DECEMBER.
SENATOR TED CRUZ IS JOINING
HERSCHEL WALKER THIS WEEK ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL AND THEY BOTH
JOIN ME LIVE RIGHT NOW.
ALL RIGHT, HERSCHEL, ARE YOU
FEELING ANY PRESSURE?
THIS COULD ALL COME DOWN TO
GEORGIA.
>> WELL, TO BE HONEST WITH YOU,
I FEEL NO PRESSURE BECAUSE I WAS
BUILT FOR THIS.
AND I'M READY TO GO OUT AND WIN
THIS SEAT FIGHT FOR THE PEOPLE.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
HERSCHEL WALKER.
I'M FOIGHT FOR THE PEOPLE
BECAUSE SENATOR WARNOCK DONE
EVERYTHING AGAINST THE GEORGIA
PEOPLE.
VOTED AGAINST THEM.
HE GAVE CRIME TO.
THEY HE GAVE THEM INFLATION.
HE PUT MEN IN WOMEN'S SPORTS.
I'M GOING OUT FIGHTING FOR THE
PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: ARE YOU GOING TO DO
ANYTHING DIFFERENTLY THIS TIME
AROUND THAN YOU DID LAST TIME?
>> WELL, THE ONLY THING GO
DIFFERENT GO INTO SOME OF THE
PLACES I DIDN'T GET TO VOTE TO
MAKE SURE I GET THOSE VOTE.
THEY NEED TO KNOW THAT I'M THERE
FOR THEM.
I THINK SENATOR WARNOCK HAS
PROVEN WHO HE IS THERE FOR.
HE VOTED WITH JOE BIDEN 96% OF
THE TIME.
THOSE PEOPLE NEED TO REALIZE
WHAT HAS HE DONE SINCE HE HAS
BEEN IN OFFICE?
DO THEY HAVE MORE MONEY IN THEIR
POCKET?
NO.
DO THEY HAVE -- LOOK AT THAT
UTILITY BILL?
LOOK AT THE THINGS HE HAS DONE
SINCE HE HAS BEEN IN OFFICE.
AND I GOT TO SHOW THEM THAT AND
I GOT TO LET THEM SEE THAT
BECAUSE HE IS A HYPOCRITE AND
BEING A PASTOR, I SAY THIS:  HOW
CAN HE KEEP THE OLD MIGHTY OATH
TO THE ALMIGHTY GOD AND HE KEEP
IT FOR THEM.
HE HASN'T KEPT IT FOR NEITHER --
NOBODY, IT PROVES THE TYPE OF
MAN HE REALLY IS.
>> Jesse: CRUZ LEAD BLOCKER
HERE.
OPEN SOME HOLES FOR HERSCHEL.
WHAT'S YOUR STRATEGY GOING TO
BE?
I MEAN THIS IS DOWN TO THE WIRE.
>> WELL, LOOK.
I THINK THE STAKES ARE ENORMOUS.
ONCE AGAIN, THE FATE OF THE
COUNTRY DEPENDS ON GEORGIA.
AND SO FOR THE MEN AND WOMEN OF
GEORGIA.
I THINK THEY ARE ENERGIZED.
WE ARE LEHR TO RALLY RIGHT NOW.
WE GOT OVER 2,000 PEOPLE THAT
ARE HERE RIGHT NOW THAT HAVE
COME OUT TO SUPPORT HERSCHEL.
HERSCHEL IS GOING TO WIN THIS
RACE.
AND I GOT TO SAY, THE ODDS ARE
VERY HIGH THAT CONTROL OF THE
SENATE IS GOING TO COME DOWN TO
GEORGIA.
THAT MEANS ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY IT MAKES A HUGE
DIFFERENCE WHETHER YOU LIVE IN
GEORGIA OR YOU DON'T WHAT
HAPPENS HERE.
THE ELECTION IS ON DECEMBER 6TH.
I WILL SAY TO EVERY PERSON IN
GEORGIA, THE COUNTRY IS COUNTING
ON YOU, COME OUT.
BRING YOUR FRIENDS, BRING YOUR
FAMILY, BRING YOUR LOVED ONES,
YOU ARE STANDING UP AND
DEFENDING THE PEOPLE OF TEXAS
AND TO EVERYONE ELSE, RIGHT NOW
PLEASE GO TO TEAM HERSCHEL.COM.
TEAM HERSCHEL.COM, MAKE A
CONTRIBUTION, THEY ARE GOING TO
SPEND MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TRYING TO ATTACK THIS
GOOD MAN.
IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK AND BUT
IT IS GOING TO BE INCUMBENT ON
ALL OF US TO STAND UP AND SAY,
LOOK, THE COUNTRY IS READY TO
TURN AWAY FROM THE INSANITY,
FROM THE CRIME, FROM THE
INFLATION, FROM THE OPEN
BORDERS, FROM THE CORRUPTION,
FROM THE ABUSE OF POWER OF THE
RADICAL SOCIALISTS THAT HAVE
TAKEN OVER THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU, JESSE,
HERSCHEL WALKER IS GOING TO WIN
THIS RACE.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT NOW ARE YOU
GUYS GOING TO HAVE DESANTIS
THERE TO CAMPAIGN FOR YOU OR ARE
YOU GOING TO HAVE DONALD TRUMP
THERE TO CAMPAIGN?
ARE YOU GOING TO BRING IN THE
HEAVY HITTERS LIKE THE DEMOCRATS
DID.
>> I'M BRINGING IN EVERYBODY.
EVERYBODY THAT WANTS TO HELP ME
WIN GREAT PEOPLE OF GEORGIA
BECAUSE THEY DESERVE THIS SEAT.
SENATOR WARNOCK WENT TO
WASHINGTON AND HE FORGOT ABOUT
ALL THE GEORGIA PEOPLE I'M NOT.
THE GEORGIA PEOPLE ALL OF MY
FAMILY NO MATTER WHAT THE COLOR
OF THEIR SKIN.
ONLY THING SENATOR WARNOCK SEE
IS BLACK.
HE DON'T SEE THAT THERE IS OTHER
PEOPLE THAT LIVE HERE AS WELL.
HE MADE STATEMENTS LIKE AMERICA
NEED TO APOLOGIZE FOR ITS
WHITENESS.
MAKES STATEMENT LIKE AMERICA,
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM WITH THEM IS
RACISM.
WHY DON'T HE GET OUT OF RACISM
AND LEARN REDEMPTION.
LEARN FORGIVENESS AND LEARN TO
MOVE ON AND MAKE THIS COUNTRY
BETTER TOGETHER.
WE CAN'T DIVIDE THIS COUNTRY.
WE GOT TO COME TOGETHER AND
THAT'S HOW WE MAKE IT BETTER.
>> AMEN.
>> Jesse: NEW NAME IS TEAM
HERSCHEL.COM, ARE IS THAT THE
NEW NAME.
>> THAT IS IT.
I WANT EVERYONE TO GO TO TEAM
HERSCHEL.COM.
BECOME A PART OF TEAM HERSCHEL.
>> JESSE EXTEND AN INVITATION IN
PARTICULAR.
I WANT TO INVITE JOE BIDEN TO
COME CAMPAIGN FOR RAPHAEL
WARNOCK AND KAMALA HARRIS COME
CAMPAIGN FOR RAPHAEL WARNOCK AND
STACEY ABRAMS TO COME CAMPAIGN
FOR RAPHAEL WARNOCK.
THEIR AGENDA IS RADICAL AND IT
DOESN'T REFLECT THE VALUES OF
THE PEOPLE OF GEORGIA THAT'S WHY
HERSCHEL WALKER IS GOING TO WIN.
>> Jesse: SEND BETO THERE AS
WELL.
TELL EVERYBODY